hallo liebe leute wir sind heute in
unserem büro hier in berlin und bei uns
ist matt hall o mat ist selber mein isar
germany zuschauer gewesen so wie ihr
mittlerweile ist ja teil von unserem
team geworden kann man sagen
matt hat schon die ersten videos in
amerika produziert easy englisch
vielleicht habt ihr das gesehen und er
macht noch einige andere sachen mit uns
unter anderem hat er sich überlegt diese
woche mal eine easy german episode zu
drehen
red was fragst du denn die leute in
berlin unser team heute ist duzen und
sieht sind als amerikaner uns ein anfang
ist ein schäbiger thema für mich und so
ich habe die frage aber die leute
gestellt
ja super schwieriges thema sogar für
deutsch wesel gespannt in manchen also
in vielen sprachen gibt es das ja gar
nicht diesen unterschied mit der anrede
und wir freuen uns jetzt auf deinen
antworten hier ist ein mikrofon
so wird sprachlos und wir haben eine
frage vor anfang es ist ein bisschen
schwierig duzen und siezen zu verstehen
können sie mich das erklären
also sitzen würde jemanden zb ein wenn
du respekt bewahren möchte dass du
kennst denjenigen noch gar nicht da
musst du sie nutzen wenn du pas du mit
jemandem bist wenn du den schon kennt
wie deine freunde oder so dann das zu
bieten außer derjenige der neue bietet
ihr an dass sie ihn zu duzen darf ja das
ist nicht wenig wie in england unter
jungen leute sind üblich dass man sich
duzt aber älteren leuten sagt man sie
wenn dir anbietet oder selber du sagt
dann kann man so sagen
aber es ist immer eine frage von
verachtung des des älteren des
würdigeren menschen nicht insoweit kann
man da keine feste regelung treffen
nötig
diese dutzend wird immer üblicher arbeit
ist auch immer ein bisschen plump
nein nein also sie
sagt man normalerweise zur etwas älteren
menschen
do
kann man zu diesen menschen auch sagen
wenn das gut ihr angeboten wird also
wenn diese menschen sagen kannst mich
guten ist es okay und bei jüngeren
menschen sagt duh in berlin darf alles
im deutschen ist die höflichkeit formen
wenn man leute nicht kennt zum beispiel
und respektvoll ist dann sieht man bei
freunden freunde duzt man und fremde
sieht man das ist nur eine frage
je nach alter dutzend leute und exakt
kann es mir auch dutzend ältere leute
nehmen das halbe also ganz übel also
ältere leute würde ich erst mal sitzen
und jüngere leute kann man ruhig duzen
und siezen ja personen die man gut kennt
und bekannte freunde die dussmann und
fremde leute sie sieht man in der regel
förmlicher so zum beispiel die polizei
man muss den 17
die sie zum anderen sind beamte wenn man
die duzt schlecht nutzen wenn sie
jemanden besser kennen
so sitzen also ist normalerweise eine
respektperson zieht eine respektperson
beispiel lehrer oder eltern oder so
wieder eingesetzt vor allem ältere
leiter und duzen ja so können freunde
dutzend leute mit dem ziel schon
vertraut sind ja so soll man sieht immer
benutzt dann wenn man bietet dann ist es
okay voll nutzen
ja also meistens ist dann okay wenn sie
fragen kann ich nutzen dann sagen die
meisten jahr
naja sitzen ist er seine respekt vorm
das war
die man nicht kennt und oder mit links
und leute mit dem man ziemlich sage ich
mal englisch die könnte man nutzen also
oft sagt die man von sich selbst heraus
das mich dutzend gästen interessante
frage normalerweise also ich wurde so
erzogen dass ich gelernt habe
menschen die älter sind
autoritätspersonen zum beispiel
bist du bei einem termin beim arzt oder
wo auch immer david gesiezt vor allem
leute die älter sind als du siehst du
ich bin jetzt zum beispiel eine person
ich bin sehr offen ich bin sehr
kommunikativ und ich immer das gefühl
wenn man selbst baut man automatisch
einfach irgendwie eine wand auf also es
ist sehr viel von mir und ich mag's
lieber informeller darum sich meistens
die leute also meistens alle egal ob das
menschen sind in meinem alter oder ob
das ältere menschen sind kann ich ihnen
sagen also als ich jung war
wo denn nur geduzt wer mein freund meine
freundin war klassenkameraden die
anderen die sag ich mal auch von meinem
alter oder etwas älter waren
aber nicht irgendwo näher an mir dran
die wurden gesiegt die große auch als
mein sohn studierte er der ist jetzt 42
da wurde alles geduzt
also es ist eine gute idee zu fragen
oder nur du zeigen und fängst immer an
wenn diejenigen nicht kennst zu sitzen
immer okay und so gibt es einige
situationen oder sowas
denn wenn man hat duzen oder siezen
benutzt
es kann dazu kommen wenn du anfängst zu
duzen dass du doch schon angerempelt
wird in dem kennen wir uns
beispielsweise ich gehe zum arzt der
duzt mich da bin ich sehr vorsichtig ich
ihn auch die mütze oder kappe bin
behandlung bei einem alten professor
nach der duzt mich aber wäre so eine
gleichstellung als ob ich bin ich mich
ihm an biedere und macht man nicht wenn
er dann sagt na gut ich heiße frites
oder oder mohammed in dem dann kann man
natürlich noch eingehen so gibt es ein
beispiel wo man dann benutzt und es ist
peinlich oder oder mag man sauer
mich würde es jetzt nicht sauer machen
vor allem nicht wenn ich einen akzenten
ausländischen akzent hören würde dabei
aber vielleicht so offizielle termine an
der bank oder irgendwie sowas oder
polizisten dass ich so ein zeichen von
einem gewissen abstand voneinander neven
du irgendeine kommt und sagt hey ganze
gerede geben sage ich dass man die
letzte nutzt zb wenn man da jetzt
schüchtern ist oder nimmt dann nimmt man
sind aber unangenehm oder man sagt okay
fangen wir noch mal von vorne an dann
halt mit sie das ist halt wenn man jetzt
zum beispiel vor gericht ist oder
irgendwo anders die leute sollte man in
der regel sitzen
aber wenn ich jetzt auf der straße die
man ansprechen dann sieht sich den auch
in der regel es seit es sei denn das ist
ganz junge leute oder dass man also
meinen vater zum beispiel nutzt jeden ja
und da kam es öfter vor dass leute
gesagt haben ich kann mich also sie
müssen nicht mit sie ansprechen und
wenn ich zum beispiel ein lehrer das ist
peinlich oder wenn ich im polizisten
nutze macht man auch nicht zum beispiel
in der schule früher fand ich es eher
unangenehmer und da das ist eine ganz
witzige sache weil eine oberschule bei
uns also in der oberstufe das ist denn
11 12 13 im gymnasium
da wird man auf einmal gesetzt weil dann
bist du 18 und wie gesagt ab 18
sieht man meistens die jugendlichen die
halb erwachsenen und auch lehrer die ich
seit der fünften klasse zum beispiel hat
nämlich immer mit vornamen und du
angesprochen haben
die mussten mich dann in der 11 sitzen
und frau sagen
und das war dann doch irgendwie nicht
unangenehm aber ein sehr sehr komisches
gefühl
ja also zum beispiel wenn man unterricht
sitzt und dann plötzlich so sagt er
kannst du mir mal kurz erklären zum
lehrer und dann sagen sie mir kurz
erklären damit das war dein episode von
heute hätte was mich jetzt interessiert
ist bis zu den jetzt schlauer geworden
mit wirklich ich habe es so viele
verschiedene antworten bekommen und ich
denke mich dass die deutschen sind sich
nicht so sicher selbst sie sind sich
selbst nicht so sicher das ist nämlich
leider der fall beim duzen und siezen
dieses thema ist
na ja ein thema was auch sehr
unterschiedliches in deutschland
verschiedene generationen behandeln das
anders in verschiedenen städten wird das
anderes gehandhabt in verschiedenen
sozialen schichten auch in firmen kann
das anders sein in manchen firmen nutzt
sich jeder jeder duzt den chef in
manchen anderen firmen ist das unmöglich
also wir hoffen dass ihr vielleicht
einen kleinen einblick bekommen habt
danke mir dass du dabei warst und wenn
ihr auch mal bei der kampf vor der
kamera stehen wollte sie kämen dann
schreibt uns einfach eine e-mail
wie immer an info at easy - languages
dot org
wir freuen uns auf euch ja und wenn ihr
uns unterstützen wollt auch ganz wichtig
für uns denn wir
wirklich von eurer unterstützung und
unsere unterstützung sehr wichtig für
uns dann supported uns gerne beim
patchen und abonniert unbedingt unseren
kanal
denn dann werdet ihr mehr und regelmäßig
in die german sehen dann gewissen
schauen und bis zum nächsten woche war
sie zusammen